take a very sharp knife
bring the pork belly towards you so
you're over it you've got all that
pressure and weight using the tip of the
knife i'm just sort of
nicking it and go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife
take your time turn it
180.
this time what we're doing is just sort
of cutting those nice little sort of
diamonds but as that starts roasting on
top it starts getting nice and crispy
take
your handfuls of salt and just sort of
rub it in
bend it over in all those cracks
really helps to get a nice crisp
crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavour and to keep the meat succulent
i'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables
crush and peel three whole cloves of
garlic and add to the fennel olive oil
in
in
i like the
nice strong
aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds
delicious star anise
in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
[Music]
just sear
the top of that fat that locks in all
that amazing flavor then i'm gonna flip
it over and get it nice and crispy
and then i want fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now
some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can just smell that light
fragrance from the fennel
allow the wine to bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol has burnt off time to
add the stock now the stock goes in
just underneath the skin so it roasts on
top all that meat under there probably
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes
crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and brazes at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never get
up to temperature
smells incredible
slow roast the pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock
has evaporated
put that onto the board
it looks stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavour packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat
take a couple of slices of bread and
it's like a perfect sponge because you
just lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that
fat if you want the perfect fried bread
trust me stick that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard
whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
[Music]
with your pork belly
always use a nice serrated edged knife
you can hear that
[Music]
that is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is going to almost
melt in your mouth you've got that sweet
meat under that crispy
belly of pork
what an amazing way to cook a very cheap
cut of meat
[Music]
stir through chopped mint pile onto
toasted bread and finally for a lovely
salty tang crumble over some creamy feta
cheese
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine
the juice of an orange